we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
hey david this is nick from connecticut
i've been a member of the show for a
couple years now and I was just watching
episode this week where you read a
letter from viewer named Christy yeah I
pretty much make minimum wage myself and
I've been a level-two donated to the
show for a while and then when you had
the YouTube problem I removed my hatred
for T discount and talked to my sister
until a membership as well and then
building on patreon precisely for that
reason cuz you provide a public service
man you should you should you should be
funded by the government for what you do
so uh thanks a lot keep up the good work
dusty yeah so a lot of reaction I I once
told you a couple weeks ago now that
someone once wrote to me saying I like
your show but I'm not gonna pay for it
because I don't want to fund your
bachelor lifestyle when I have a family
and I responded I think a better way to
decide what programs to support is are
the programs worthy of support in your
estimation and we heard from that single
mom last week saying she's a member
because she believes it's important to
fund the show we heard from this caller
who earns minimum wage but says he finds
the program worthy of support and I
really hope that that's the question
people will ask when they say do I want
to support this not is David a bachelor
versus what's my situation or whatever
if you can afford it is the program
worthy of support that's really the key
question yeah especially because I don't
think we're gonna get any of those
government grants no other suggested but
hey give that man a raise you know he
needs it if if Mitt Romney wanted to
take funding away from Big Bird I don't
know that the david pakman show has
federal funds coming to it anytime soon
we've got a great bonus show for you
today david pakman.com slash membership
we'll get you instant access a patreon
contribution of 5 bucks at patreon.com
slash david pakman show will also get
you instant access to the bonus show and
we will speak to you then